Aozubillahi minas shaytan ar-rajeem lismillahir Rahmanir Raheem Alhamdulillahi khalikal wujoodi minal 'adam wa ja'ilin noori minal zulam wa mukhrijis sabri minal 'alam wa mulkit tawbati 'alan nadam Fanashkuruhu 'alal masa'ibi kamanashkuruhu 'alan ni'am wa nusalli 'ala rasool hilakram lishsharafil asham wa nooril atam wal kitabil mahkam wa kamalin nabiyina wal khatam
Sayyadi waladi Adam aladi Bashar Rabhi Aisabnu Maryam wada'ali ba'asatihi Ibrahimu alaihis salaam hina kaana yarfa'u kawa'idabaytillahil Muharram Fasallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam wa alaadba'aihi khairal ummam aladi barakallahu bihim ka fatan nass alaaraba minhum wal ajam
Wa sallallahu ala amir al mu'mineen alanza al baqeen Waqa idl ghuril mahad jaleen ghalib ala kulla ghalib matloobi kulla taalib mawlana ali ibnabi taalib alhamdulillah alazi anzala ala abdihil kitab walam yaja Allahu aywaja alhamdulillah alazi lam yat takhiz waladan walam ya kun lahu sharikun fil mulk walam ya kun lahu waliyum mina zullah wa kabbir hu tadbira
Alhamdulillah, Alladinahmaduhu wa nasta'ainuhu wa nastaghfiruhu wa nukminu bihi wa natawakkalu alaih Na'udubillahi min shururi anfusina wa min sayyyati 'aamalina Man yahdihillahu fala mudillala wa man yudlilhu fala hadi alah Wa nashhaduan laa ilaha illallah Wahdahulah Sharikalah Wa nashhadu Anna Muhammadana Abdullahi wa rasuli
Sallahu Allahu ta'ala bilhudawa deen al-haq liyuzhirahu ala deeni kulli wa kafa billahi shaheeda Wa nashadu anna mawlana alibnabi taalib wa sihu wa ziru fa sallallahu alaihim wa ala alaihim wa salim huum tasliman kasiran kasira Allahumma la 'ilmalana illa ma alamtana inna kaantal alimul Hakeem Allahumma alimna bima yanfaana wa yanfaana bima alamtana
Allahumma inna na audubika min ail min la yanfa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min ainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashfaa Fa amma baadiyakullu subhanahu wa ta'alafi kitabahil kareem bada na kulla audubillahi mina shaytana regim bismillah rahmanu raheem rabbish rahli sadri wa yaserli amri wahlul qdatam millisani yafkahu kawli
Allahum masabit na indal mawki bila ilaha illallahu wallahum majalna minal latheena aman wamila salihat wa tawa saubil haq wa tawa saubil sabr.
Ameen yar abdul alameen in the previous session we took an Islamic view of the terms friendship and love so we looked at the different types of good and bad friends that the Quran talks about and we studied the various stages of love
in how it grows and develops from attachment to, you know, the all-inclusive form, which is hope.
Hope is basically pure love and it includes within it all the previous stages of love.
So, you know, hope is sort of a union of all these 10 stages of love.
And so in the light of these terms and definitions, you know, we're going to move that conversation forward to understand
the linguistic meanings of words like Allah, Rab, Rahman, Rahim we all have some sort of an image of you know like Allah we think of it's just a name it's like we have names Allah has a name and that name is Allah right but Rab we all understand it to be you know sort of we think of all these different names as just one entity basically names of
the same entity but actually it's quite different and each word actually gives us a window into understanding you know what that entity means from all these sessions that I've talked about and you've looked at the power of the Arabic language that's one thing that it does which no other language can do is that each linguistic meaning of the word it gives you
sort of a perspective of what that entity truly means and that's why we're gonna look at these different words linguistically to get an idea of exactly what is expected to us what should be our perspective what should be our understanding when we use the word Allah what should be our understanding when we use the word Rabb what exactly are we talking about right so that really gives us you know more power
when we execute our various forms of worship it sort of gives us a more clear understanding of what to do and as we understand these words you know keep the stages of love in mind and then that'll help us determine how much Allah loves us and this is another benefit of linguistic studies that not only do we understand how we're supposed to love Him but also how He loves us
because the thing about love is that love inspires love right you have to receive love to be able to give it and then you have to give love in order to receive it and the more this give and take takes place the more that love increases so that's how it works right love engenders love so today we're going to begin by looking at this word Allah
the word Allah it comes from the root word ilah okay now generally we use this term ilah to mean God like I said but in reality ilah is a very generic term in the Arabic language like a book or a car you can have many types of books and you can have many types of cars right it's it's not specific similarly
There can be many types of ilah.
There are many types of ilah.
In the English language, we have two types of articles.
We have the indefinite article, which is a book, a car, and then there is the definite article, which is the book, the car.
Right now, what's the difference between a book
and the book.
A book is a generic term, right?
It could mean any kind of book, any book.
But when I say the book, I'm no longer talking about just any book.
I'm now referring to a very specific book.
Right?
So it's the exact same principle with the word ilah.
The word ilah is a generic indefinite term that can be used for many things.
There can be many types of ila, just as there can be many types of books and many types of cars.
But when I apply the definite article the to it, what is that definite article in Arabic?
It is al, aliflam, right?
When I apply that definite article to the word ila, when I make it al plus ila,
That combination generates the word Allah.
You understand?
Allah is basically Al-Ila.
In other words, Allah is the specific form of the genetic word Ila.
Allah is actually Al-Ila.
And that's why based on the rules of Arabic grammar, the Alif of Allah
is dropped when it joins with Al and the Al merges with it to become Allah right so basically that's where Allah comes from when you apply the definite article of Al to Ila it becomes Allah and this is why in order to understand the linguistic meaning of the word Allah we must first understand the meaning of the word Ila right okay
Now ila is a composite word and it has a slew of meanings.
So today the first thing that we need to understand is what I mean by a composite word.
It's really important to understand, you know, how composite words, these words, how they work in Arabic before we can proceed because all of these terms that we're going to talk about like, you know, Raab, Rahman, these are all composite words.
So once you understand how it works, then it'll make it easy to understand all these different words.
So think of a composite word like a jigsaw puzzle, right?
Every piece of the puzzle has a separate independent meaning Okay, every piece of the puzzle has a separate independent meaning but then all these meanings come together to create a composite image of what that word means just like
Each individual piece of a jigsaw puzzle has a certain image on it, but then when you join it together properly, the final image comes forth, right?
And you can see the entire picture.
It's the same concept of a composite word.
So let's say if the word ilah has four different meanings and, you know, for example, it has four meanings A, B, C, and D, then the sum of those meanings will give us the complete understanding of the word ilah.
You understand?
The meaning of ilah is not A or B or C or D.
It is rather the sum of all those meanings.
It's A plus B plus B plus C plus D.
So all meanings of the word ilah apply together at the same time.
That's how this works.
That's what a composite word is.
In English you know one word can have multiple definitions and they can have their own context.
Same thing in
Arabic right each individual variation of the root word can have its own meanings but then when you combine it together it forms one single meaning and inshallah this will become clear as we go along.
Now let's look at the different linguistic meanings of the word ila.
The first
And the primary meaning of the word ilah comes from the variation of alaha ya aluhu.
And the verb alaha it literally means to worship.
So the first meaning of alaha is the entity that is the focus of our worship and obedience.
That's the first meaning.
What is worship?
It is an extreme form of gratitude.
We covered this in the previous sessions that worship is the extreme form of gratitude.
It is that highest form of that sense of gratitude where the benefactor becomes so desirable, so important in your life that you are forced down on your knees in humility.
So when you completely succumb and surrender
your will to the will of the beloved right when that happens that beloved becomes your ilah that is the first meaning of the word alaha of that variation alaha so for instance if you are obsessed about your job if you are obsessed about your career to the degree that you put it above and beyond everything and everyone else in your life
then you've made your career your ilah.
You understand?
If your video games, sports, TV shows, children, wealth, if these are the things that commands and rules your heart, right?
If those are the things that make you bow down before them, then by definition, these things are your ilah.
If you are madly in love with someone to the point where that person controls and dominates your every thought, every action, every decision, then that beloved is now your ilah.
Because ilah is the one you worship, the one you submit and obey to without question.
So the ilah says jump and you say how high, that's alahas.
So that's the first meaning.
I'm sorry, that's Yala.
Right?
So what I just explained is the meaning of Yala.
Now let's look at the word Allah.
So just to rephrase, because I think I used the wrong definition.
Defining Ya'ala and thinking of Allah.
So Ya'ala is the one who is the object of worship, is the one you literally worship and who dominates your thoughts, right?
So that's Ya'ala.
Sorry about that.
Allaha is another variation of the word ilah and it is used for a child that is thirsty for the milk of its mother.
That's Alaha.
Literally, that's imamate.
Alaha is used for a child that is thirsty for the milk of its mother and is desperately crying for it.
Parents can understand what I'm talking about.
Have you seen a baby crying for milk?
And if you remember the desperation on that baby's face,
And what does the baby do when the mother offers it her breast?
It turns to it with this hungry passion, this hungry thirst.
It just latches on.
That's Allah.
It is the entity that you desperately and inevitably turn to with a passion, with a desperation.
It is what you desperately and uncontrollably turn to.
in your every single moment of happiness and grief.
That's Allaha.
So, you know, for example, some people have really bad sugar addictions.
Right?
If there is a...
I think I'm one of those.
You know, you put a chocolate in front of me, that's it.
Right?
Some are addicted to smoking, some to drugs, some to parties, some to movies.
So anytime you feel happy or depressed, the thing that you desperately and uncontrollably turn towards for comfort, by definition that becomes your ila.
Because you find peace and comfort in the arms of these masters.
And we become their obedient slaves.
So when these masters command, we have to obey.
When the desire commands certain people to smoke, they have to obey.
So, when you can't stop yourself from eating that last stub of ice cream or watching that episode of your TV show and you must watch a movie every night or you must play a video game for hours every day at the stake of no matter what, then you are completely and loyally devoted to these things.
Because you just feel that you absolutely have to do these things in order to feel happy and satisfied again.
And so you turn to them in this form of desperation that a baby turns to its mother out of its thirst for milk.
And, you know, this applies to each and every one of us in some way or the other.
You know, we all have such ila in our lives.
It doesn't make us horrible people, just makes us human, right?
So, and what we're doing today, you know, by learning these meanings,
We're in a sense waking up to see these masters for what they really are.
And I think that's the first step towards any change, right?
It's just waking up to see the reality, not be deluded.
So don't feel overwhelmed by these definitions because, you know, once I put it into the context of Allah, all of this will make sense.
But for now, just understand that these are the linguistic meanings of these words.
So Yala means
that entity of worship, the one that you worship that you feel extreme gratitude for.
And then Alaha means is that emotion of a child turning, crying for the breast or the milk of its mother.
So that desperation, that deep-seated loyalty, that's what Alaha comes from.
And imamate is so beautiful because of this child, right?
When it's crying for milk, there is nothing else that will satisfy the child.
You cannot distract that child.
You cannot sing to it.
You cannot give it toys.
You cannot do anything.
That child is going to keep crying until it gets what he wants.
And that is how we are in our lives.
There are certain things in our lives we are so addicted to that nothing will satisfy us until we have that
whatever we fulfill that desire so that's why I think the imagery that these words create is so beautiful because it really answers every possible question of what the word alaha means you want to understand alaha just look at a baby crying for milk that's it and everything that that child or that baby is facing at that point is the meaning of the word alaha this is why I find this language so beautiful
Okay, so that was Allaha.
Now let's look at Walaha, right?
Another variation.
This Walaha is someone you are passionately in love with, someone you cannot stop thinking about, someone you are obsessed about.
Right?
Now, this derivative Walaha is used when someone goes insane by the loss of a beloved.
That's the imagery.
That's imamate in front of you.
Someone who loses his mind by the loss of a beloved.
The mother who loses her child is called Muwalla derivative of the same root, Muwalla.
This is a mother who is suffering that extremely excruciating pain and grief over the loss of her child.
That's a Muwalla.
It is that kind of passionate and obsessive love.
In Urdu also we say Wale Hana Mohabbat, right?
Mad love, crazy love.
So it's the same root, it's Walaha.
So if there is someone in your life that you are obsessed about, that you are always thinking about, that you're madly in love with, you know being apart from this person drives you insane, you cannot stop texting, you cannot stop calling, you're constantly looking at their pictures, you know reading their
emails, texts, whatever missing them with a passion then you are in a state of wallaha and by definition that person is your ilah okay so that's another meaning of this variation of the word ilah the next one is aliha right so there's alaha and there's aliha aliha is literally
Not linguistically, literally used for something that you lean on.
Something that you put your entire weight on.
So for example, you know when you're exhausted and you lean on something and you put your weight on that thing, then that thing that is supporting you is Aliha.
Right?
So old people, they walk with a cane.
That cane is called Aliha.
So in your life if you're banking on something you know for example you're just you're banking on your finances, your property, your houses, your cars, your jobs you're depending you know you just completely depend on your social status, your friends, your neighbors, your children then any of those things that you lean on are all your ilaq.
So if you're putting all your eggs in one basket, metaphorically speaking, then that basket, that thing, that person is your ilah.
That's aliha.
Another derivative of the word ilah comes from waliha.
We saw walaha, now this is waliha, which means to become astounded, to become astonished.
to become mesmerized and you can see how waleha and walaha are connected strongly connected with each other right because the one that you are completely astounded by is the one you will passionately fall in love with so that it's amazing how these words are so interconnected you cannot separate one from the other so waliha means to become astounded become astonished
So you know how kids create role models and actors and musicians and these hip-hop artists, right?
How kids today want to be like them, live like them, think like them, dress like them, talk like them, walk like them.
So you know when this movie a few years ago with Aamir Khan because most people here in this group today are
in the session today watch Indian movies so you know when this movie Gajni came out with Aamir Khan and he had that haircut with the line going across in the top right do you know how many kids actually shave their heads with the exact same style so when when a kid you know when someone feels that they have to go out and shave their head to look like Aamir Khan because that's how he looked in the movie Gajni then they've made Aamir Khan their ila
because they are now astounded and astonished by him.
So by definition, ilah is the one or waleha is the one that you're completely and utterly impressed by, the one you wish to imitate, the one you want to be like.
Now that could be a person, it could be a thing, it could be a profession, it could be anything.
Anything that mesmerizes you, grips you, takes complete control of your decisions is
another derivative of the same root ila.
Alright.
Let's see.
So these are the various meanings of the word ilah that we looked at.
Now let's go over them again.
Just a quick review of who and what an ilah is.
The one we worship and obey is our ilah.
I'm just looking at the root word.
I'm not looking at the variation but
they all tie in with the same root.
So the one that we worship and obey, the one we are completely devoted and loyal to is our ila.
The one that we turn to in utter desperation to find comfort is our ila.
The one we are passionately in love with, the one we obsess about is our ila.
The one we lean on for support
Physically, mentally, emotionally, psychologically, in whatever shape or form, that is our ila.
The one we are astonished by, mesmerized by, the one we are utterly impressed by, we want to imitate, that's our ila.
Now if you combine all these definitions together, you get the meaning of the word ila.
So ilah means the one that we worship.
ilah means the one that we are devoted and loyal to.
ilah is the one that we turn to for comfort.
ilah is the one we're passionately in love with.
ilah is the one we use for our support, we turn to for support for all our needs.
ilah is the one we are mesmerized by.
All of this combines together.
This is what I meant by a composite word.
The variations have their own independent meanings, but when you join all these variations together, it gives you the complete picture of the root word.
Okay?
So this is what the word ilah means.
And they're all interconnected, like I said.
Because the one you are passionately in love with is the person you will be completely devoted to.
That is the person that you will lead on.
That is the person you will turn to for comfort and support with other desperation.
Right?
Separation or distance from that person will drive you crazy.
You will literally submit to obey, you know, you will obey every single thing they want, every single desire they have, you will fulfill.
In other words, you will worship that person.
So you can see how all these meanings, they merge together to create a complete picture.
So that is how a composite word works.
So now based on these meanings of the word ilah, you can see that we all have numerous ilah, right?
We personify and objectify these definitions in some way or the other.
Some have ilah in the form of people, family, friends, children, parents, actors, musicians.
Some ila exist in the form of objects, houses, cars, bodies, jewelry, food, video games, movies, right?
And then some have ila in the form of jobs, careers, recreation, drugs, sex, whatever.
So we all have hundreds if not thousands of entities in our lives that meet the definition of the word ila.
I hope everybody can see this.
right?
Now, here is something that I want you to think about and this is where the conversation gets really interesting and a bit scary.
I said that all these people and things in our lives that meet the definition of the word ila is basically what they're doing is that they give a physical form to one of the definitions of the word, right?
So for example by definition ilah is the one we are loyal and devoted to.
ilah is the one we turn to for comfort.
And so now if smoking or movies or video games is what I turn to for comfort then in a sense in that sense in that context these activities are taking on a physical form of that definition of ilah.
You see that?
It was originally the definition is a concept and then we give it a physical form.
in the form of you know smoking or movies or whatever.
So for example you know if Elah is the one that astounds and astonishes you you know if Shah Rukh Khan or Sylvester Stallone or I don't know Lady Gaga these are the ones who astound you impress you to the point that you want to be like them then you know you've given the definition of waliha a form
You've personified that definition in the form of Shah Rukh Khan or Salan or whoever.
You understand?
Now, here is my question.
What is the definition of an idol?
You know, we talk about idol worship, right?
What is an idol?
An idol is an image or representation of a god used as an object of worship.
That's the standard definition of an idol.
It is the personification or the objectification of someone or something.
Isn't it?
Who creates idols?
We create idols.
Idols are man-made creations, aren't they?
Man creates idol and who objectifies and personifies the definitions of ilah?
We do.
We decide that we are going to turn to smoking, movies, drugs, alcohol for comfort.
We decide that we are going to be completely loyal and devoted to our jobs, our careers, to Facebook, to Instagram.
We choose to fall passionately in love with wealth, power, fame, social status.
Nobody does that for us.
We do that.
In other words, we are the creators of our own ilah, just as idols are man-made creations.
Do you see the similarity there?
You see where I'm going with this?
Because generally we think we are Muslims, right?
And therefore we have nothing to do with idol worship.
but the scary reality is that we are literally surrounded by thousands of ilah which are self-created idols and we worship them loyally on a daily basis.
Every person, every object, every concept, every idea that we personify or objectify in a sense is an idol
that we made for ourselves with our own hands so in that sense we are all idol worshipers right it's a painful reality but it's true so if you really look understand the word of the meaning of the word Eli
then the concept of Shirk, it doesn't seem so alien now, does it?
This is why there is a Hadith of Rasulullah in which he says.
Let me see if I can share this with you.
He says, Ashirku fi ummati akhfa min sairin namali fi laylat zulmati ala sahratis sauda'i.
That Shirk, idol worship,
or associating partners with Allah is more hidden in my nation than the movement of a black ant in a dark night on a black stone.
It's that subtle.
This is how unaware we are of our own idol worship.
Now in the final analysis who is at the center of my idols?
I am.
Now why did I create these ilah?
Why did I create these idols?
What motivated me to build my idols?
My desires, right?
All my idols, all these idols that I have created are basically a product and a creation of my own passions and my own caprice.
My idols exist because of my wants.
Now, Allah says in the Quran, Have you seen those who take their desire as their god, as their ilah?
The one who takes his own desires as his god.
So, Allah is basically asking the messenger Do you not see these people who take their desires
you know their cars, their houses, their jobs, their wealth, their fame, their pleasures as their ilah?
Do you not see this person who has taken smoking, drugs, alcohol, movies, video games as their ilah?
Who has taken you know Shah Rukh Khan, Salman Khan, Adele, Stalin as their ilah.
Allah is asking Rasulullah and then he says ...
Do you really want to be responsible for these people on the day of judgment?
Because that is what Rasulullah wanted, right?
He wanted to convert as many people as he wanted, these kuffar, these mushrikeen, these rejecters, disbelievers, hypocrites, all of them.
He wanted to get everybody into the fold of Islam.
And so Allah is actually asking him, don't you see these people, how they've taken their desires as their god?
They're not going to accept me as their God.
They've taken their own...
their desires are their God and He's asking do you want to be responsible for these people on the Day of Judgment?
May Allah protect us from being amongst those.
So worship of the self is the worst form of shirk that there is.
When gratitude turns into self-gratification that is the worst kind of shirk.
Idolatry has nothing over selfolatry if that is a word.
And so we are constantly committing shikh by taking our desires and making them our ilah.
So human beings are in a constant state of self worship which is exactly what prevents them from truly worshiping Allah.
but that is the default state of mankind and here is where Islam comes to the rescue by the negation listen to this carefully by the negation and the destruction of these self-created idols emerges the understanding of Allah by the negation and the destruction of these self-created idols
comes the understanding of Allah.
Who is Allah?
He is la ilaha illah.
You see?
He is everything other than what you take for your ilah.
If we break and destroy each and every idol that generates from the desires of ourselves, when the Kaaba of our hearts is empty of these idols,
what we will find left is Allah.
What is the first thing that Rasulullah did after the conquest of Mecca?
And here, really, if you understand it, we think that these are just random events, right?
But just look at the...
forget the history of Islam from the way it occurred.
Look at it from Allah's strategy.
Just think about it in the sense that Allah planned it this way.
There's going to be a Kuffar, Mushrikeen, Mecca is going to be surrounded by these people.
dominated by these people my messenger is gonna come he's gonna spread the messenger the message of Islam it's gonna take a long time for it to come through 23 years of hard work but then he is going to conquer it and Islam is going to prevail and it's gonna and it's just gonna you know flood the entire city so think about it as Allah strategy right and now look at this event
of what happened in the conquest of Makkah.
What is the first thing that Rasulullah did after the conquest of Mecca?
He cleansed the Kaaba of all idols.
That's the first thing he did.
There were 365 idols in and around on the top of Kaaba and he destroyed each and every one of them one by one.
He had so many people, they could have all worked together to break all the idols together.
No, but he uses Maulana Ali as his sword to break each and every...
he doesn't break it himself.
He makes Maulana Ali.
He literally uses Maulana Ali as his hand as a sword to break each and every idol.
One by one.
And this is the exact same exercise that we all have to go through in our lives
You know, just as Rasulullah , just as he conquered Mecca, we have to conquer our Nafs.
And then just as he cleansed the Kaaba of all idols, one by one, gradually, we have to gradually cleanse our Kaaba, our hearts of these idols, one by one.
And the greatest and the most powerful idol that stands in the Kaaba of our hearts is our own nafs, our own passions.
And this is why I think our credal formula is so incredibly amazing because it attacks the very root of this problem.
La ilaha illallah There is no ilah except Allah.
There is no one, no person, no thing, no concept, no principle
no ideology worthy of giving form to except the one who is free of all form and that is Allah and so by the negation of our self-made idols by the elimination of our self-created ilah emerges the ilah what happens when you add the definite article
to ilah, you get the ultimate ilah which is Allah.
So our credal formula of la ilaha illallah is the idea of negating the multiplicity of our self-created ilah to affirm the one true ilah which is Allah.
It is the exercise and the practice of making ilah
into al-ila by taking away the form of ila and applying it to Allah.
And this exercise, this practice of seeing Allah as the one and only, the ultimate target of all these definitions of the word ila, by making him, eliminating these ila will make him al-ila, it will make him Allah.
So in essence, la ilaha illallah is the exercise of isolating the various definitions of the word ilah that we learnt about and making them specific to Allah.
Right?
So this means that now Allah is the only one I worship and obey.
So la ilaha illallah now means, in a sense I can say la ya'ala illallah.
I will not worship anyone but Allah.
If any other ilah conflicts with the commands of Allah, then I will disobey that Allah to obey the al ilah which is Allah.
This does not mean that I cannot enjoy life, right?
The difference is now that Allah is at the front and center of my worship and obedience.
And as long as nothing else takes the form of worship for me, it does not conflict with Allah's worship and obedience.
I can enjoy my life.
I can do whatever I want.
There's so much I can do I can enjoy to the fullest degree.
Right?
La ilaha illallah now means that
You know Allah is going to be the only one that I will be completely devoted and loyal to.
Above and everyone else in my life.
Even my own parents, my own children.
You know I will only serve Allah and no one else.
But then I'm happy to serve my parents because Allah has commanded me to do that.
But I'm serving them because Allah has commanded me.
I'm taking care of my children because Allah has commanded me.
You see?
You see how when we change our thinking like that, how we apply the Al to the ila.
Parents can be ila, children can be ila but when I actually do it because Allah has commanded me to do so, now I have destroyed them and made...
I now have given a specific form Al ila and I'm now doing it because Allah has commanded me to do so.
and so now I'm happy to hang out with my friends I'm happy to go to parties I can watch movies I can do whatever I want as long as my ultimate loyalty and devotion lies with Allah if anything or anyone challenges that loyalty then I must choose Allah over them if there are certain kinds of parties that if I go to
it would be in disobedience of Allah then I should not go to them.
If there are certain kind of movies that I should not watch because they will conflict with what Allah wants then I should not watch.
But other than that there are so many other movies, so many other parties that I can go to.
Right?
So you understand the difference?
This is how we make him al-ilah.
That yeah I am willing to be loyal to the various ilah in my life but not at the risk of
upsetting the al-ilah.
That is what the meaning of Allah is.
So you can see how you cannot understand what Allah means until you understand what ilah means.
You see that?
So now la ilaha illallah means la alaha illallah.
That Allah is the only one I will turn to in utter desperation for all my needs and comforts.
This does not mean that I cannot ask help from my family and friends.
This does not mean that if I'm hungry and out of a job I should sit on my **** and not do anything because Allah is the one who's supposed to feed me.
No, absolutely not.
I will turn to whoever I need to for whatever I need.
The difference is that in the back of my mind I will remember that these people are simply a means to an end.
Allah is the one providing for me.
and he is using these people as the means the asbab to get the job done and therefore my ultimate ask is always going to be of him Ya Allah I need this I turn to you for the fulfillment of my needs provide me with the means and resources that will fulfill my needs in the way that pleases you because it is you and only you
who is the source of my provision nobody else but then if I have this in the back of my mind I can turn to Ayaz and say hey I'm out of a job is your company hiring can you help can you put in a good word for me can you give my resume to your HR department but not with the understanding that Ayaz is the one who's giving me the job or helping me but understanding that Allah is the one who will eventually help me but I can use you know I can turn to
I ask for help, there's nothing wrong with that.
So understand the difference?
Because in this case, yes, Ayaaz is becoming my Allah because I'm turning to him with a need, but he's not my Allah.
Because Allah is the one who is in the back of my mind that I see him as the specific one who's going to provide my provision and Ayaaz is just going to be the means for it.
So I hope you can understand the difference.
I hope I'm being clear enough because this is a very difficult concept and this is why you all need to really reflect on this for yourself because it'll really help you bring out the understanding of these meanings.
So now La ilaha illallah also means Lawalaha illallah that Allah is the one I am passionately in love with.
Allah is the one I'm completely obsessed about.
From the moment I wake up to the moment I go to sleep, Allah is the one that I think about.
This does not mean that I have to sit on my janamas all day.
Or you know I spend my entire day doing tazbih.
No.
I can do whatever I want.
But everything reminds me of Allah now.
Everything in the horizons and my soul becomes a sign for me, pointing me towards Allah, reminding me of Him.
Isn't that what love does?
You look at the flower, you see the beloved.
You look, you know, in life.
If you're in love with another person, everything reminds you of that person.
The flower, the rainbow, the sunset, the frog in the pond, right?
They all remind you of your beloved.
Love is an obsession.
It is a constant connection with the beloved.
So now what happens if Allah is at the back of my mind, even my beloved reminds me of the blessings of Allah.
That Allah is the one who put this love in my life.
You know the story of Hazrat Ayyub?
He was put to this great trials to test his faith.
So according to Hadith of Rasulallah, once Allah mentioned the patience and gratitude of Hazrat Ayyub,
to his angels.
So Iblees came and he spoke to Allah and said that the only reason this man is grateful to you is because you have blessed him with so much.
This is what Shaitaan said.
He put this question right before the angels and he said that.
That you have given him so much that is the only reason he is grateful.
If you hadn't given him that, he would no longer be grateful.
So Allah started taking things away from him.
He took his possessions away first, right?
Then his house, it collapsed right in front of his eyes, killing all his sons.
Can you imagine that?
Just think of that.
Standing in, you know...
God forbid.
A person who is standing in front of his house and he watches his children are sleeping in that house, he watches the entire structure collapse on his children killing all of them, what would he go through?
Do you know what came out of his mouth, of Hazrat Ayyub's mouth when he saw that?
Alhamdulillah.
That is what he said.
that is his awareness of Allah that is his awareness of who Allah is and that is how he's made you know all his ila specific in Allah and if that wasn't enough he got this horrible disease where his body got infected with worms that would eat his flesh
So Allah put Hazrat Ayyub through this extreme form of trials to test his faith and love for Allah.
And he succeeded with flying colors.
And this was not just to prove Shaitan wrong, it was to prove...
You see, you can look at this two ways.
How can Allah be so cruel?
If really Hazrat Ayyub loved Allah so much, why would He put him through this?
So did he really need to prove shaitan wrong that desperately?
No.
But by putting Ayyub through this test and seeing him...
Allah knows what's going to happen.
Allah knows that Ayyub is truly, you know, truly faithful to him.
But by putting him through this test, he just set a precedent for the entire world.
And then when he completed, when he succeeded in this test, Allah took it all away.
Allah asked him to bathe in the spring water that he set out for him so Hazrat Ayyub took a bath in it and he was completely cured and what's interesting is that years later someone asked him you know how is your health now Ayyub and you know what he did he sighed and he said you know the days of my illness were better than my days today.
The days of my illness were more beloved to me than my days of health today.
And that man was shocked.
He said, How come, Ayyub?
And he replied that when I was ill, every single day Allah would ask me once, How are you doing today, Ayyub?
And now that I've been cured, Allah no longer asks me that.
So I miss that love and care that Allah showered upon me during my days of illness.
That is Waliha.
That is Muwalla.
He doesn't care about his own pain and suffering.
All he cares about is that Allah is no longer talking to me and asking me how I'm doing.
I'm not feeling that love from Allah.
That is extreme passionate love.
In which a person is driven to insanity in the absence of his beloved.
Right?
So now la ilaha illallah has become la walaha illallah.
Then
You can keep applying this to all definitions.
La ilaha illallah now means La aliha illallah.
That Allah is now the only one I will lean on for support emotionally, psychologically, financially, physically, in every way shape or form.
This doesn't mean that I'm not going to go see a doctor if I'm sick.
It doesn't mean that I'm not going to ask my boss for a pay raise if I deserve it.
Doesn't mean I'm not going to ask my family and friends for help if I need it.
I will continue to do all of those things.
But my ultimate support is going to be from Allah.
He is the one that I will ultimately lean on.
He is the one who will cure me of all my illness, not the doctor.
He is the one who will increase me in my provision with my pay raise, not my boss.
He is the one who will fulfill all my needs, not my friends and family.
Can you just imagine how liberating that would be?
How many of our complaints with people and life would just disappear?
We would no longer have to blame someone that we trusted for disappointing us because he was not meant to be.
I never leaned on that person for support to begin with.
Therefore, there is nothing He can do to disappoint me.
You see, you cannot have a disappointment without expectation, right?
And if all my expectations are from Allah, then nobody in this world can disappoint me.
Not even Allah, because Allah, and we learn this in much more detail in the session on Rahman and Raheem, that everything He does is for my benefit, whether He takes from me or He gives to me.
Because He loves me.
So if I got what I wanted, then Allah was the one who gave it to me.
If I did not get what I wanted, it was not meant for me.
Who knows if getting what I wanted would end up being the worst thing for me in the long run.
I mean we all say right, be careful what you wish for.
Because sometimes we desire something so bad and that turns out to be the worst thing in our life.
Right?
So that is aliha.
Now la ilaha illallah finally means la waliha illallah.
That Allah is the only one that astounds and impresses me.
This does not mean that I should not appreciate anyone in my life.
I should not praise anyone or not feel impressed by anyone in my life.
No.
What this means is that I must see Allah behind the praise.
If my child does really well in school,
MashaAllah, praise for Allah that He made my child intelligent.
There are many children who aren't.
MashaAllah, that Allah made my child intelligent.
If I'm mesmerized by the sunrise and the sunset, then SubhanAllah, praises for Allah for creating these beautiful things for me and giving me the eyesight, the time and the willingness to appreciate it.
You know how many people in this world are so burdened by their problems that they, you know, the last thing they will think of is going and appreciating sunrises?
That's a gift from Allah to me.
And what I'm doing is I'm taking the praise for the beauty of sunset and attributing it to the creator of that beauty.
And all now La waliha illa Allah is that nothing will impress me except that which impresses Allah.
Who impressed Allah the most?
Rasulallah .
In Rasulallah I have the example of what impresses Allah.
And so if I want to impress Him, what should I do?
Try to become like Him.
Isn't that true?
Right?
I mean, why would I try to imitate Amir Khan and Shah Rukh Khan and dress like them and talk like them?
Why?
Because the idea behind that is impressing the world.
What is that going to get me in the end?
The same dunya, the same people when I die, what are they going to do?
They're going to throw me in a ditch and throw dirt in my face, right?
So what am I working so hard to impress them for?
Shouldn't I just impress the one where it actually matters?
And we know exactly who impressed Allah.
It was Rasulullah , it was Mullanahali, it was...
This is why we study Seerah.
We don't just study Seerah from a historical point of understanding how the events of history took place.
No.
We study history to study their character.
to understand how these people live so that we could emulate and try to be like them because the more we are in imamate of RasulAllah the more we will be loved by Allah.
So what happens through this exercise is that we get to the true concept of Tawheed.
The concept of Tawheed is not that Allah is the ultimate deity in a hierarchy of deity.
The concept of Tawheed is not that Allah is the ultimate God in a hierarchy of gods.
No.
The concept of Tawheed is that there is no other deity.
There is a complete elimination of all other deities.
Except the one and only deity which is Allah.
It is the transference of ilahiya from its generic form to one specific being that has no form.
That is the challenge and the goal of La ilaha illallah.
Right?
And how do we do this?
Slowly, gradually, one by one, one idol at a time.
Just with the sword of La ilaha illallah we keep striking at the idol.
We're not going to break every idol in one strike.
It might take a lot of strikes to quit a habit.
It might take a lot of effort
to reject the desire.
We will fail.
You know, every time you strike an idol and it doesn't break, that's a failure.
Every time you try to leave a habit and you fail, that is just one strike.
Try again, try again, try again.
Our problem is...
and this applies to me.
I can see me talking to myself right here.
Like I give up, you know, I try, I try and then when I fail, it's like, Oh, you know what?
It's not gonna happen.
Why?
Just keep trying.
So what?
Eventually it'll happen.
So, you know, when people learn about these ideas and, you know, one of the reactions is, you know, oh my God, you know, I cannot do this.
Why not?
You know, and that is the wrong concept because the conquest of Makkah should be in the front of our eyes when we're trying to deal with the situation.
Look at how the Kaaba was not cleansed in one strike.
It took a lot of effort.
So, it's gonna take a lot of effort on our part.
But the thing is, when Allah is at the front and center of all of these efforts, it becomes so easy.
Because there's no grudge.
There's no, Oh my God, why do I have to do this?
You know, this is terrible.
Because the idea is now that I'm doing this to please Allah, I'm doing it happily.
I want to do it and that makes it so much easier.
The more you want, the more power it gives in your strength.
Right?
And the most easiest way of doing this, the first step of doing this is Salat.
Our Salat has the concept of breaking idols within its very nature because look at the times of Salat, the most busiest times that we always have.
you know, waking up from our deep sleep, right smack in the middle of the day when we're busy with work, right at the time when we are leaving for work, came home tired, sunset, you know, that's when we have to do Maghrib and then now we're sleepy and tired after a long day of work.
We've eaten so much that I can barely get off the chair and now I have to do Isha.
So Salat has been placed at this, you know, right at the center of the most uncomfortable times and in order to do Salat every single time you have to break an idol.
Because as soon as it's time for prayer the first thing you will have to do every single time is stop doing whatever you're doing.
So now if I am gluttonous, if I eat a lot, Isha will stop me from eating a lot because I know I have to do Isha.
So I will not let that food make me so heavy and feeling so you know full that I am not able to do my salat.
So this is the beauty of salat.
It forces you to leave whoever you're with and turn your face towards Allah.
Salat
is the very concept of la ilaha illallah in action.
You want to see la ilaha illallah in action in your life?
Salaat.
Because that is exactly what you're doing, breaking idols.
And so this is the journey of la ilaha illallah.
It's a difficult journey and every journey requires provisions, right?
That help you get through the journey.
And the provision for this journey is the knowledge of Allah.
which is what we're doing in these sessions.
The more knowledge we have of Allah, the more we will be amazed by His glory.
The more amazed and astonished we are, the more passionate we will become in our love for Him.
The more passionately we love Him, the more we will be obsessed about Him.
The more we're obsessed about Him, the more we will worship Him and submit to His commands.
The more we worship Him, the more we will turn to Him seeking His refuge.
The more we find ourselves under His powerful shelter, the more we will lean on Him, the more we will put our weight on Him for support.
Because in the final analysis, love engenders love.
The more we realize how much He loves us, the more we will love Him back.
The more we love Him back, the more intense He will get in His blessings and mercy.
Wa ista azana rabbukum la inshakartum la azi danna ko
And your master has said that if you are grateful, I will give you more.
I will increase in my blessings.
Wa hir dawa nami hamdulillahi wa bilalameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasuli saydna Muhammadan khatimin naveen wassaidul mursaleen, wala khiva wassi alibnabi tahilbwasir malalayimatim zuriatima taibi na tahireen salawatullahi wa salamu ali majmaeen al-fatihah